pourquoi benjamin biolay benjamin biolay
non pas les halls et s'est attaqué aux
miss météo du grand journal
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait qu'il ya eu près
il a dit qu'en fait les miss météo voler
le travail des actrices des véritables
actrices en prenant les miss météo comme
des espèces d'ersatz d'être d'actrice
kick willy colin tillier louise bourgoin
charlotte le bon qui sont d'anciennes
miss météo c'est étonnant parce que
lui-même et chanteur et acteur donc
c'est curieux qui tacle écoutez je vais
vous dire un truc qui s'est fait cette
info est ce qu on n'a pas un peu
d'accord ils m'ont mis un bandeau
mahbouli qui est météo a pas du tout je
connais pas ça il sait très bien ses
traits au palais à paris la place d'un
chantier très très bien mais jamais je
connais pas même si je crois il a mal
parlé de moi un jour ben voila je te
connais par coeur c'est beau quand on
place un impôt rapidement t'inquiète pas
assez calme à miauler je crois il a mal
parlé de moi un jour et je sais plus
mais qu un jour j'ai joué mais si je le
croise je pense que je dois là il verra
ses repas gras de mots bien ça va mieux
et je connais les mecs qui parlent comme
ça sur twitter et tarifs de nombreux
édiles sont fan de toi merci des chiens
ils n'auraient pas besoin d'enrichir qui
l'iphone qui toi qui m'avait taquin jour
à 8 ans mais bon voilà je connais les
mecs qui tacle sur twitter au nom
japonais
on veut rappeler merci ça m'a fait du
shérif mais j'aime bien quand même
j'espère le rencontrer bientôt quoi
combattre et non je connais pas le
pauvre voilà mais si je le vois je
dirais pourquoi tu parles mal de moi et
puis si ça doit si ça doit se taper ça
s'apprend et son pouvoir et où tu savais
qu'avec la parole bien sûr mais non si
je dois ce cap est vraiment un stade
france non je tapais j'ai pas me taper
benjamin biolay les mecs on va
sérieusement plus l'homme est serré mais
moi ce n'est pas le mec moi je me
taperais envoyez-moi des candidats
sérieux